no not the clap you stupid idiots all
right Oh name is markiplier and I'm not
we're clapping I'm not waiting Lance
that's a lie that's actually true pick
certain happen I'll stand up if you want
me to also he can fly so this is pretty
toilet oh can we all fly again hey
zombie take her out why no don't I'm
gonna go meet the target I want you guys
to find the cannon at me okay so anyway
behind the candidate you about that wire
the cannon well oh yeah that was awesome
oh yeah so um about last episode being
the last episode yeah those a lie yeah
we like that we lied I uh I hope
everyone cried tears and was like
gnashing of teeth and wailing of
lamentations of your yeah this isn't
firing far enough move us closer
zombies whoever yeah just move this
whole things on me you have that
capability right he does hey guys each
are you eating marshmallows uh potato
chips
all gone hungry um alright let's see if
you guys to modify the can I hit the
nipples no nothing there bulls Oh hit
the nipples I'll go with nipples those
nipples are nice no the best marks seen
for a very long time shut up
just cuz I'm fat and alone doesn't mean
I haven't seen nipples you like look in
the mirror all the time you look worried
for me you [ __ ] me jaw no not like that
not a squirrel ate me up everybody out
there who's listening that did not
happen there's a lie would you censored
me would you put me I'd put me so hard
I've gotten past censoring these
episodes so that's basically a no-go
apparently wool does not stop a
cannonball it occurs to me you guys are
like a little bit too low Tommy
now if the cannonballs go farther by we
have absolutely no capacity for yeah
well I can fly we cannot do anything we
are is that a crescent moon I didn't
know that was possible
what where what oh yeah of course it is
there phase of the moon you idiot Osam
bees back he was gone
gob I move this closer to the Slendy man
and his nipples okay I'm the target
zombie get closer to the nipples Tommy
you're such a dick zombies
not really but whoa whoa whoa I wanted
to kill us
zombies awesome I wanted to kill whoa
whoa whoa Oh what the hell Oh God that
was terrifying look at the shape of the
cannons Wow
oh wait yeah it's now penis cannon Oh
just came in officially a penis cannon
Manny iOS will be proud man I've heard
of like balls of steel but balls of
obsidian is kind of it oh we hope you're
dead oh yeah you're dead weight yeah get
me get me get me get it's so fun oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] you got that no no what the
hell are you dead yet
teleport no that worked a shitload of
armor on so yeah go on decreasing the
range of it boom oh yeah I just decrease
the range at all on to me in the face go
away haven't assumed that you tried to
save Bob by mark what of course of
course I did the TNT nuzzles gently into
his bosom really beautiful
yes I'm gonna be over here and shoot me
whoa hello that is kinda scary boom oh
the chest Arena will begin in four hours
war yes no what does that mean it's kind
of weird they don't seem to be exploding
over here I don't know what the deal is
also I can't hear it so I gotta make the
sound effect uh that's my favorite thing
what there should be a death count at
the bottom of the screen
hey guys I want to try that that would
be really funny actually I try that
actually
it's just it takes a lot of editing you
know it's hard to do fiction in Rome
yeah you're asking so much of me I gotta
like write words on the screen and then
you know that can't be right I don't
have all my stuff back yet well hello
yeah not how was that one for range it's
not exploding yeah I don't know what it
is okay
now back onto the user suggestions ah
let's see here um let me up
let's see marks manly man ranch by Ryan
Hook
uh bleeping arena sleeping us there's
already spleef arena in here let's see
get no potato that shoots out oh he's
what a potato that shoots out waves I
like it what does it even make people I
could be a spud mega noun that shoots
out other noun oh no oh I like it
best idea I've ever had let's make a
verb that nouns other verbs yes I think
you mean although you heard me okay I
want to make a [ __ ] that doors other
walking's holy crap that makes so much
sense have a contest on who could build
the Tahoe penis house
but Bob has to build his out of wood and
leave since he loves treehouses wouldn't
avoid penis how I that's I feel like the
world on all these suggestions are like
bad mad lives where every time there's a
now what if he's on every verb they put
in penis oh wait I've got one that we
can do
Willy mcLeese does I believe that's your
real name
says that we should do a sculpture of
the dancing banana smiley face or just
mindlessly to nothing and entertain us
Oh pickled liver big smiley fan I don't
think we can do that aimlessly
entertaining people
blood build that I I don't think we have
the character of it for if we can get
like somebody else and we export wait
can we explore the island and built in a
new area sure we can fly so we can go -
I know that's what I've been wanting to
go over the mountain for so long okay
we'll go over the freakin Mountain god G
can we build a roller coaster no wait
you can build a roller coaster that's a
stupid idea whoever came up with that
idea is stupid
Oh whoa Wow Molly oh yeah Bob and I like
Molly we don't even let you more that
was Molly see ya oh sorry
[ __ ] ass hahahaha really [ __ ] ass that's
your go to it so Archer said it doesn't
he I don't watch Archer he says it so I
think Archer is a stupid show Paul for I
have to go I have to go I'm sick now I
ate raw beef whoa oh oh I'm trying to
fill up but it's not working out can you
not fly wait oh no that all good god my
mind is shattering
drink some water noon now now down a
dome Laden done des mmm oh it's more
Mountain the fish room what is this I go
in I answered that question snow
mountains what I get over the freaking
Mountain come over here there's a new
area with more mountains I'm gonna go
past these mountains - I've already lost
you guys that's the bad
I don't know where you guys are going
over the mountains gah so so am i I am
now on the peak of Mount come avoid
Kaluga if you say [ __ ] watch it come on
watch it Mountain being attacked by a
bug now I want you I'm now at the peak
of Mount Jubjub yeah we should build a
big jump job on it [ __ ]
what does it jump job look like Marv you
know they're like you know shorten cap
yellow eyes you know it's a job job you
know what's funny is I was uh I was
going over some Google searches for some
reason I was happened happening to look
through my search history and I came
across the search the series of queries
that I did well I tried to figure out
what the [ __ ] you meant when you said
Jeb job [ __ ] the one that I opened then
read for the like the longest was an
article that was about how Jubjub it
pronounced Yub Yub is a sound in the
wood in the in the joe is language oh
and it's oh no so on in the presence of
Princess Leia so it's sort of like
royalty or like stranger or beautiful
traitor something like that yeah but
it's spelled Jubjub but it's pronounced
yellow so there's aa bewbs no yeah for
the love of God everyone who's watching
I know you were just dying to find out
about the jawan dialect huh huh oh
you're welcome
I found a cabin in the woods I think
this is the highest peak Bob I was here
first so I was here first
get out here you followed me up here I
claim this in the name of markiplier I'm
gonna come kill you take it blah ah what
you just blocked me ah you know what
there's the highest that you can build
so this must be the highest peak I'm
gonna jump off it
I have no idea where you guys are even
at we're on the highest patty how hard
can it be to see the tallest mountain
you douche its Oh mine's not loading
anything it's hot it's probably actually
pretty hard considering that I can't see
the ground from yeah that's true that
probably true hey waits here hi hello
Wade hi this is what you get here this
is the absolute heart portage is the
highest we can build like maximum build
height and we shall call it mount ,
Hannah Waja mount wanna hock a loogie
yeah I thought hock a loogie mount one
Oaxaca you know when I first heard that
mount wanna bang your mom you know I
know that's an old joke but you know oh
yeah
weren't we supposed to get the whole
internet in on Wade's mom jokes ya know
we were we were everybody in the world
judging by that reaction ya know that's
right Oh Jesse made me promise Jesse's
another friend of ours and he makes this
is a douche she's not a dude she makes
the world this is such a douche mom
joked and everybody in the comments
below write the best your Wade's mom
jokes that you can come up with and I'll
read them in a future episode at some
point you can you follow marina this is
our spleef arena isn't it these are blue
fake this is easily exploitable enough
no this bill rehearsed
first off is built wrong oh why why hey
on Wade you seem a little bitter about
something maybe your weight lacks what
is important we ever do to you yeah
we're our entire lifetimes
what are we ever done but we deserve
that we have deserve such treatment we
haven't already done to your mom why do
they ask such awful a simple common
sense questions guy alright we're gonna
talk to them they're not your friends
Bob stop we're gonna basically farina up
here Oh what is that oh I know what that
is you know what that is
dear silly wait if you want to kill me
you can try but I have a lot of armor oh
wait wait come here come here wait Oh
I picked these up when you died last
time where's more i neva cuz I was done
I knew that you would not go and get
them or I stole them from you and now
I'm getting the bag you're not giving
back my pants I don't have any pants are
cuz um because I quit all-beef his pants
or stone cobblestone I lied okay Lady
Gaga on it
zombie can you hatch me out of an egg
creepiest egg that's ever existed I
don't know dude with my empty beer
bottles uh more beer
oh god what if we was a bobcat read my
poker face whatever these episodes come
to what seriously what have we done
I need more white Wow this Russ singing
Justin Bieber babe babe babe oh I've
never actually heard a Bieber song I
don't think I never heard that
Bieber song I think it's like I wanna be
the first I don't know I've never heard
that song before
so parent all of my viewers have just
left I know or they're all cheering on
because they're young enough to like
Justin Bieber how many people out there
actually like Justin Bieber oh what that
none actually I don't know I I don't
listen to enough is a song gonna get
said good no I hate him Bob last it's
not centered shut up
don't care Bob what happened did you go
away Bob went away Bob oh oh whoa oh I
was gonna attack I have this piece of
meat eating a zombie with my meat sounds
like something Molly would want me to do
with your making
oh god that's wrong zombie king all his
health all a knock him off or knock him
off your meat on his forehead oh yeah I
just totally beat him with my meat I
know who's good that's the best meat
handling I've ever
in my life I mean seriously you got
serious mad skills in terms of beef
handling always he didn't even take any
fall damage she's just alive down here
now right took some fall damage go kill
him
hit the spleef arena is almost done I
know why whoa I'm a bit demanding our
night Wade be really cool for her sword
not just raw beef to the fight with you
fight with that beef and you let with
that Latin oh I don't think so that was
him okay I need my white wall why well
why well why well yeah why I've got a
hit of a hundred and see four more times
to kill him how do you know that because
it tells me is held 158 157 out of 200
156 let me see this come hit him I think
a big bow zombie king let's see no I
don't see any oh there we go I see him
ah oh oh oh let's back him with my meat
- maybe that'll help if we both
double-team them with our meat that
could prolly help I think I think Bob
that's not hail I don't know who I am
hey I thought you guys heard me I said I
had to get a beard oh we didn't hear
that some other should happen we're
beating souls with our meat come on help
yeah sorry I hate you okay one down I'd
have just destroyed the art that I help
my girlfriend hang on the wall really
meticulously a while ago you can see it
in the video yeah I use my chair back I
fall over a little and slam my share
into the wall and the art that's
supposed to be there not there where you
go it's looking on the floor and it's
broken nose I'm a bad boy sorry mother
zombie okay yeah I can't see you right
now haha wasn't answering you wait I was
okay talking I wish that's already gonna
say that anyway I always said Zambo meat
had sound effects whenever you hit
something with so it's like slaps I'm
not I don't hear the
oh are you a markiplier Pigman now yes
wait what what happened I need food soon
I'm on fire why I'm on fire in a good
way or a bad way
Oh bad way like before with the bad way
I was quoting an earlier episode of
Minecraft first God actually I said
sounds like personal problem Bob's order
said yeah a good way or bad way right
yeah you're right man I missed it guys
the simplistic days where we just tried
to build stuff and failed can we do that
some more do that tomorrow yeah Tommy
I'm sad now that I broke my are dumby
can we go back to that Beach is that
still exist I don't think it exists
I probably doesn't exist anymore oh the
memories that we which had though beats
where we first went to in the first very
first episode
you're a number you write it ever come
on zombie remember I remember like it
was yesterday wasn't yesterday why am i
floating around in purgatory ok Wayne's
World
aha you got it yeah I I did get it I was
just I was letting the viewers get it
for themselves
Tom for the super happy ending oh is it
the mega happy ending I don't remember
yeah I think it's mega happy happy
ending
all mazes are there I would have done it
if it were
oh god oh my oh no guess what I'm doing
uh beating your meat
this zombie Kings only gonna take sixty
eight more credits I got our visting ice
for some reason why I don't know do we
have anything we need ice for because I
have a bunch of it no no read oh wow I
forgot that this pickaxe COS actually do
stuff
look I'm a cow whoa
I love these axes ah anyway so what are
we doing we're waiting for zombie to get
possibly that beach that we were at
oh [ __ ] I'm stuck in the ground why are
you that I don't know Wow
no way oh no way this isn't the beach
it's different Beach what the hell
happened here
went hunt TP except that's not right
Bobby don't port me this isn't quite
what we had this now this isn't the same
places where we were in the beginning
but I don't want to go I've only got 30
more hits oh god it's so weird some
other before - yeah why it's marked the
only Pearson person that's there the
only Pearson it's on me oh snap
I'm trying to open a Guinness with a
screwdriver right now yeah if I stab
myself in the face don't be surprised
trying to open a screwdriver with a
Guinness that's what you said no I said
a Guinness with the screwdriver who says
what I said no with the Guinness yeah
you had to take their cuz I realize that
you're a dumbass oh I'm pretty sure it's
not
twist off it's on camera Bob
yep I my audio is not on K I got a sword
you want all he's fully reeled I got it
I got a sword can I have a sword
epic vows almost like I got it worked it
worked it did what worked
a screwdriver Guinness thing I was doing
hey I didn't even shed her any glass I
shared some glass in the picture behind
me ha ha ha that sucks
it's Mandy gonna be mad I already told
her that's why it belongs Oh wish you
did you and CP accept me or what no I'm
not there anymore
Oh al
Oh dad we haven't done anything we got
only eight minutes left
what seriously who dropped a diamond
sword we got that oh man wait did you
get that yup good job that's your reward
for killing him why my being hit I don't
know I'm not doing are you hungry or
poisoned or zombie eat No oh I really
would like some pants hey Jordan we all
join me in the No Pants
look I'm not wearing I don't have pants
I'm not wearing pants right now
understand that oh you know about real
life aren't you yeah never read
something before we started recording um
what was aam be talking to you we have a
new mob arena for Halloween really let's
go let's go yes what is it
ma Halloween ma na j-man but we have to
clear our inventories first ah god I
could so much crap zombie curse is an
image so I'm so lazy I'm so lazy oh god
I can't be bothered clicking all these
things Oh God
it was just so horrible there we all
think you zombie I'm so lazy
alright now going you could clear mine
too woo oh ah people are here the the
young the unwashed masses that are my
viewers who defender and healer those
are the only two classes I like that I'm
gonna be a healer I might be a healer
how do i heal I don't even know Oh
splash potion of healing okay then that
probably explains it uh-oh sweet guys
here working on it wait how our stupid
are you I'm dropping stuff off I want
you be I hear when I was playing World
of Warcraft plus I keep excellent pick
everything up the healer Thank You Sambi
um I'm gonna drop off my money God why
are people joining us everyone knows
that I don't like people so why do I
have
redstone and coal what's the point of
this are there only two options for
spells defender or healer
there are only two options how do I cast
spells I don't know God I explain hmm
this place looks ominous everyone hit
the iron block I know that that's when
we're ready the iron block hit the iron
block there we go whoo I guess whoa it's
Bob a healer who doesn't like a spell
they don't know I like a spice which no
I'm a healer I'm a healer all right so
what's the dealio here this we should go
into the public chats we could talk
strategy oh this looks so weird yeah
ruch is that your bruise your slogan the
whoosh of whoosh is that your slogan
yeah yeah who is this my chair ah oh
whoa sweet what I had typed up here no
I'm not gonna die [ __ ] I'm gonna die I
healed myself anyone want a potion to
splash healing let me know if you need
healing more carny deal where oh no I
got it oh hey dropped dynamite oh that's
bad
I probably bad thing I've died I'm
picking up the archers ah mobs drop oh
Jesus yeah but we can crap stuff note to
self I can't fly now I got him
Oh double-teams I got that I got iron
yeah did you know I sold a stack of iron
for like 1,600 voxels because people
wanted to buy it from me no yep that's
how much my celebrity is my celebrity is
worth a certain number of inflation on
voxels
yep that's how great I am did I mention
how great I am
No how great are you incredible shut up
incredibly awesome uh uh oh I'm sort of
so enough to stay up here to keep the
lights on I don't know what is the
lights do I don't when I walked up there
they get right I don't know why
hello I hear zombies oh no that's a
portal nevermind look at that ceiling
that's pretty sick
oh I didn't look up that's awesome Oh to
leave there but it's cool oh so zombie
what's up with the second wave now this
is a wave timers need to be adjusted I
guess there's a long time er between
waves oh there's a zombie well the only
downside of the long wave timer thing is
a like if you get hungry you get hungry
faster uh-huh Oh hmm
meat fighting yeah we are yeah I got
cake why don't we take aa lag lag ah oh
there's a creeper you're supposed to put
the cakes down so everyone eat them yeah
I know
there it is it's right there you go to
work creeper cakes down but I only have
one cake so eat up I can't even hit
anything
Pigman man I'm totally looting the [ __ ]
out of these guys uh-huh yeah for
something I can't hit that Pigman I
can't either
I can kind of an arrows yay zombie how
do I cast spells of healing ha ha
I want to cast magic missle on why I'm
attacking the thickness when you missed
a little sector line there waiting yeah
stupid such a douche wait no no we're
not talking wait mark why don't you make
me do that
cast prayer okay how do I bind that to
something plush s base fine space prayer
I don't know I do
okay cast another ACO using bind cast
and prayer all in there I believe can't
use that command in the arena Wow hello
ah why why Bob Oh God we're gonna die I
did not know that would happen healed
did you guys get healed no I know be
healed
stop running away from my dad my dad's
ha ha ha ha god I'm trying to heal you
run away I only have so many of these
things you know
I'll get more Dimond who picked up this
oh my got it damn it damn you damn you
to heck and back I mean I didn't kill
him so I killed him saying I killed him
I killed him with my would ensue I have
4 diamonds and 2 irons what I really
need now is wood mark I need wood don't
have would give me wood mark hang on let
me get a second oh I would I miss out
that's out free I can't um Oh looking
into what ye bothe my geese I don't know
I'm trying to hug heal everybody but
keep moving around alright there's a
zombie here guys uh-huh it's dead now
though we're actually out of time
oh well better switch the next one it
for recording ever again oh we're never
recording ever again this is the last
episode ever but if we were going to
which probably switched now before the
next wave star okay alright so anyway no
no that's always star that's all the
time we have for this episode now thank
you all so much for watching
now click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always we will see
you in the next video in the next video
bye bye in the next video